I had a little framework that I applied
to the program research which I called a
4-peat framework
the program itself that means the
content people that means who is
teaching who are the lecturers out there
the third one was promotional ability to
it that means if you'd complete the
program does it help I think with
Stanford laid it was a perfect case the
last one we call whether you are proud
of building something whether I am proud
of doing this course was my criteria so
I think all four of them really worked
out what the Stanford program really
stood out to me because number one their
location being close through San
Francisco in the Bay Area which is a
technical hub if you will for innovation
and it's happening right now but also
the network that exists within Stanford
that not only connected itself to those
institutions but also abroad globally
and I thought that package between
education and network became a key
driver in terms of the choices I made in
selecting a program my career and the
work that I was doing in the school
actually I thought was a really
beautiful relationship and allows you to
actually take some of the real problems
that you were having than work and apply
them to some of the frameworks that you
are learning from the school I've been a
research scientist for over a decade and
I felt as though I needed to get
business and management fundamentals and
so I actually started searching into MBA
programs I knew that wasn't going to be
right with my schedule being a mother of
three and working full time a lot of
those programs will cry at least a
two-year coursework along with it being
financially unaffordable for me I kept
searching around in the Bay Area and I
stumbled upon a Stanford lead program
digging through a lot of the course I
decided that Stanford was going to be
the right fit for me I was really drawn
to the Stanford lead program because it
was able to resonate with the mission
which is Lee learn engage accelerating
disrupt the coursework and my
opportunity to be in the program really
spoke to that comparison to other
executive programs the online format was
really going to be able to fit with my
current schedule I'm a Bay Area native
so I've always dreamed of going to
Stanford always offering a world-class
education in terms of my options I was
able to easily select Sam for his lis
program